every one for those who don't know me
I'm Christopher kettle and I'm chairman
of Stratford District Council and I'm
talking to you on here's another very
sunny afternoon spent on the lockdown
the reason I'm talking to you is on
Friday we should be celebrating beed day
across the district it was not so long
ago a few months the detailed plans are
being made not only in Stratford but in
towns villages and Hamlet's and across
the whole country
to commemorate and celebrate the end of
the Second World War and it is strange
that only two years ago we celebrated
the scenary centenary of the First World
War armistice and now we're
commemorating another armed armistice 27
years after that one what that first
commemoration achieved was both a
realization and education of the
appalling nature of the first war and
the extraordinary bravery and the
actions carried out by soldiers sailors
and airmen in that conflict and the
devastating impact on those left behind
him home in this district we prepared a
roll of Honor of all those the district
who died in that conflict fifteen
hundred and seventy one in total about
one-sixth of the male population aged
between 20 and 40 one impacts with the
current problems has been that we have
not seen or heard from the many veterans
of what it was like to survive the rural
and very modern and highly mechanized
war very different from the trenches and
see in air battles of World War one many
of us though will have had parents of
relatives who served in the Second World
War whether in Europe the Middle East or
the Far East and again on land sea or
air
however what was different was that in
this war civilians were heavily involved
thousands died in the bombing of major
cities and like all unlike all previous
Wars
the Second World War was visible to
those at home
I was recently speaking to a gentleman
who as a child at the time but much of
the war on my farm explained that I was
seeing from the farm a night sky being
lit up over Coventry yet another bombing
range and where his mother was working
as an ambulance driver he was told it
was a special fireworks play to avoid
him worrying about his mother there will
have been many other similar memories
and from those beneath the bombs
many tragic stories for the survivors
the end of the war was a cause for
celebration and it is an enormous pity
that we cannot commemorate the 75th
anniversary as we had all planned
both celebrating and remembering the end
of that war in Europe again in Stratford
we were preparing and we'll prepare a
district role of Honor to commemorate
all those who fell in that war and yet
it is extraordinary that we cannot
commemorate the war because we are now
fighting a different war but one in
which the aggressor is silent invisible
and indiscriminate and with whom that
can be no dialogue or armistice and so
what we are seeing is a very different
army fighting again to save our lives
not only across this country but across
that globe from the front line now
staffed not by soldiers but by doctors
nurses carers the support staff and
those supporting them and also those
trying to ensure that the vulnerable are
not forgotten and that includes every
one of us either those who are still
working in essential roles or those
importantly isolating at home we all
have a part to play
but on Friday let us for a short time
forget about our current battle and
commemorate the broadcast seventy-five
years ago when Sir Winston Churchill
announced the end of the war in Europe
so in the morning there will be two
minutes silence at 11:00 a.m. if you
wish to join in on that and if you're
having a VE Day picnic in your garden
please remember stay safe and distant
but celebrate and remember both to raise
your glass at 3:00 p.m. in celebration
and remember that the Queen will be
addressing the nation at 9:00 let us
commemorate the extraordinary acts of
those in the services and the civilians
and of course those now fighting this
new war today and let us also not forget
for them and their families and it and
is traditional at the end of the speech
like this this is also god save the
queen thank you all for listening and I
hope you have a great day on Friday
thank you bye-bye